madame et le québec est une province
importante pour cette élection mais on
vous a pas beaucoup vu depuis le début
de cette campagne dont vous êtes là pour
la marche du climat mais je serai ici
encore une autre fois
évidemment j'étais essayez donc moi d'où
avec l'annoncé de pierre nantel j'adore
les temps au québec et j'espère que nous
avons plus de temps dans la campagne
mais c'est vrai j'étais ici aujourd'hui
parce que demain c'est la grande marche
de grève climatique des jeunes quand
vous voyez une jeune comme greta tombeur
qui a réussi à mobiliser si rapidement
des centaines de milliers de personnes
alors que vous ça fait des années que
vous travaillez pour cette cause là
comment vous vous sentez je pense que
quand à toi que tu es un vrai héros
maintenant elle est la seule leader
mondial qui comprend bien la menace et
prend les étapes on a besoin pour suivre
je suis étonné par l'impact d'un seul
étudiant de la suède qui l'a seulement
15 ans au début de ces efforts je suis
je pense qu'elle est comme un vrai
miracle pour le mouvement
il vous est ce que c'est l'aboutissement
de tout ce que vous d'autres écologistes
ont fait ou bien est ce que c'est c'est
les jeunes qui ont repris le flambeau et
qui sont beaucoup plus radicaux que vous
avez oui tout le monde doivent être raté
comme maintenant parce que nous sommes
presque à la maman de point de
non-retour regrette timbre garaison tous
les maux ans qu'elle utilise sont vraies
alors le paradoxe c'est qu'il va y avoir
des centaines de milliers de personnes
dans la rue en tout cas demain c'est ce
qui est prévu et en même temps il ya un
nouveau sondage qui révèle que les
canadiens sont pas prêts à faire les
efforts nécessaires pour le climat parce
que c'est toujours leur leur poche en
fait qui compte plus que la planète je
pense que la question c'est le problème
je suis absolument certaine que le canal
les québécois québécois sont prêtes il
en désir profond d'avoir leadership pour
faire les choses on doit le faire et si
je suis prêt à payer pour soi ce n'est
pas pour les citoyens de pays comme dans
une situation de guerre comme le
deuxième guerre mondiale s qui un
sondage combien on peut payer pour
protéger notre société contre un ennemi
comme ça n'ont jamais cette question c
est vraiment l'autre le mot la mauvaise
question la question c'est seulement que
est ce qu'il y est important pour vous
pour votre famille de l'avoir gourmand
qui fait les choses qui sont nécessaires
éviter la catastrophe climatique un saut
c'est la question est pour nous dans
notre club mission possible
il n'y a pas un seul chose pour
augmenter les coûts vive les citoyens et
les citoyennes
on doit faire les choses comme vraiment
à sion en voiture les choses avec un
plat qui inspire
mais pourquoi les gens voteraient pour
le parti vert parce qu'on sent qu'il ya
comme une surenchère en ce moment parmi
les partis politiques même le bloc
québécois dit qu'il est plus vert que le
parti vert alors pourquoi on vous on
veut très peu tous les autres partis va
utiliser notre colère mais c'est vrai
que seulement le parti vert est un vrai
parti catalan avec les cibles avec un
plein comme et ont annulé les oléoducs
n les gaz de schiste mettre sur pied un
système pour énergie électricité
renouvelable et pour éliminer les
voitures qui on utilise de gaz
on doit le faire et c'est vraiment
possible notre cible c'est plus un peu
sûr que les hôtes et autres pâtés parce
que c'est basé dans les séances dans
l'épreuve
mais le parti libéral propose un waf en
souhaitant qu'un canada carboneutre en
2050 en quoi votre plan à vous
nous emmènerait plus loin que ça le
problème c'est que de promesses
monsieur trudeau rire c'est bon mais
c'est pas possible arrivé à sept bus en
2050 avec le cible que monsieur trudeau
garder qui était maître people mis sur
pied par monsieur harper on doit
augmenter cet effort soit 100 fois son
tube les 60% de réduction de gaz à effet
de serre aucun d'eux en 2030 mais c'est
pas possible avec les efforts
actuellement et le même chose le parti 1
[ __ ] 1 cible de 38 % structure c'est un
peu mieux mais c'est absolument
insuffisant votre carte financière en a
fait sourciller plusieurs
65 milliards de dépenses est ce que
c'est réaliste
oui oui je suis absolument certain que
se réalise c'est pour ça que nous nous
sommes repartis avec les plus grands
majorité de notre plateforme recherchait
pas le bureau parlementaire budgétaire
etc nous avons 84 points de notre
plateforme qui sont étudiées par ce
bureau de 65 milliards de d wade mais
nous avons cherché et trouvé les
nouvelles sources de revenus et c'est
aussi dans notre plan la réalité ce que
on doit avoir société plus durable plus
égale et en même temps un société sans
carbone une société plus égales pour
aider les gens avec le coût de vie on
doit le faire en même temps
et à mon avis c'est vraiment possible ça
c'est pourquoi nous avons choisi le nom
mission possible c'est l'effort mission
facile mais c'est une mission possible
alors parlons de votre position sur le
pipeline trans monterrey vous dites on
veut on ne veut pas de ce pipeline
on va l'annuler mais on l'a déjà acheté
ce pipeline mais alors qu'est ce que ça
veut dire
nous avons acheté le viet pipeline qui a
60 ans
le problème est réservé dans la ville
quatre points vers 7,2 des valeurs qui
sont maintenant à un texte simple jamais
possible de gagner
cette monnaie qui sont pvn de marée mais
perdu l'agencé pervis et perdre mais le
prochain au lieu des 4 ans l'homme qui
coûte un autre 10 à 13 milliards
à mon avis à mon avis et pour tout les
verts on doit annuler le oléoducs et les
conventions de l'oit et son ouïe et le
pétrole canadien ou est-ce que vous
qu'est ce que vous faites si vous êtes
au pouvoir
oui nous avons fermé le robinet c'est
fini ou bien on garde le pétrole
canadian horse à bitumineux en 2030
c'est le termine à sion d'utilisation de
sable petermann yeux pour pétrole c'est
assez clair on doit réduire les gaz à
effet de serre par 60% de référence de
2005 et 2030 c'est pas possible avec
augmentation dans ce secteur la
pétrolière et on doit aussi par an
auxquels va continue l'exploitation des
sables bitumineux est juste pendant
cette période de transition et à l'an
exact donnez moi exactement mais avec
moins et loin par année en terminant
madame et si on a un gouvernement
minoritaire
est ce que c'est une condition pour vous
est-ce que vous pouvez appuyer un
gouvernement qui va continuer d'appuyer
le transmanche
le pipeline c'est impossible donc ni les
libéraux ni les conservateurs dans un
mouvement minoritaire
tout le monde va bouger un peu elle
bougeait pour nous donc façon et non
masquer le seule question qu'il n'y a
pas une choix c'est une question avec un
seule réponse on doit agir pour protéger
l'avenir pour nos enfants petits-enfants
ce n'est pas une question pour
négociations merci beaucoup à l'âme et
bonne fin de campagne
merci madame guérit pas